فما الهدف منها يا ترى؟ طالبات
افغانيات يتحدين طالبان ويتجمعن
الجزائر لمناورات درع الصحراء
وهي اول تدريبات مشتركة مع الجيش
الدفاع الروسية بالنفي القاطع.
بايدن نحتاج الى انتاج اشباه
التيار الصدري او ائتلاف المالكي
ومدتها سنة واحدة ويعد خلالها
في فصول دراسية سرية. هروب جماعي
من سجن لبناني يثير السخرية. هو
حل البرلمان او تغيير النظام
السياسي الا بعودة البرلمان. حسن
في اوكرانيا قبل حوالي ستة اشهر.
ليأتي الرد بعدها من وزارة
لاجراء انتخابات مبكرة. ليأتي
الرد من نور المالكي. لا حديث عن
شيء فظيع. مضيفا ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن كان يعرف كل
الف جندي روسي قد او جرحوا منذ
بداية العملية العسكرية الروسية
شيء عن المداهمة تماما كما كان
يعرف كل شيء عن صفقة ابنه هانتر
ملكية بينما الغرب يعيش في ظلام
دامس ويستعد لشتاء قارس وبايدن
احد السجناء الفارين يضع لايك
وتعليق على بيان الامن انه وصل
المداهمة سوى من الاعلام الرسمي
فقط ليذهب ترامب ويتوجه الى مكتب
لتصرح بعدها نانسي بيلوسي. ان
اقتحام سكن ترامب يؤكد عدم وجود
وهنا تايوان تصرح. الصين تستخدم
المناورات العسكرية لايصال رسالة
قانوني او دمر او شوه اي سجل او
وثيقة او خريطة او ورقة رسمية من
قد يصيبكم بنوبة ضحك. فقد جاء
على لسان مسؤولة الخارجية
اي شخص فوق القانون. ليعلق بعدها
دونالد ترامب ان ما حدث في منزله
المدعي العام في نيويورك
للاستجواب بشأن ممتلكات فماذا
عشرة القسم الفين وواحد وسبعين
ان كل من اخفى عن عمد وبشكل غير
ترامب صرحوا ان مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي صدر عشرة صناديق من
بين كيم وترامب بالحب حسب مقال
نشرته نيويورك تايمز ليأتي هذا
منزل الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب. تدخل بالقوة وهنا امر
وبالتحديد في ولاية فلوريدا
العشرات من سيارات اف بي اي امام
دبلوماسي امريكي سابق ان ترامب
حاول التخلص من وثائق هامة
الامر من وزارة العدل الامريكية
حسب تصريح البيت الابيض. محامو
الوصول للجزيرة وستعزل كاملا.
هنا العجوز بايدن يصرح قائلا انا
مفادها استعدوا لغزو تايوان.
ونحن مستعدون. انت على ذلك. وهنا
اقليمي تابع لنا في الصين بل
تحزم اوراقك واستعد للقادم. هنا
الصينية قولها. تايوان لنا. لان
فيها مطاعم ليا. مهلا يا جينك شو
والحساسة والتي تمس الامن القومي
الامريكي. من بينها مراسلات خاصة
تعيش اجمل ايامها. عسكريون
امريكيون يتوقعون الخطوة الاولى
اعتقد انها ستقوم بشيء. وفي عالم
حرب التصريحات هناك تصريح صيني
الصامت. بحديثنا عن تايوان. فهي
اليوم وفي ظل عقاب الصين لها لا
الفرنسي قائلا علينا ان نستعد
لحالة تقشف في الطاقة من اجل ان
رومانسية اذ سيتناولون عشاءهم
على الشموع ليس من اجل احياء
وكذلك العراقيين. ولا ننسى اليمن
السعيد الذي اصبح تعيسا. الغزو
وشلتها. وقد افاد الخبراء
العسكريون ان اول خطوة للغزو هي
يلعبون يا سادة. بهذه الخطوة قد
يمنعون تدفق اية قوة اجنبية من
العزل وهذا ما تنفذه الصين
حاليا. فاصحاب العيون الضيقة لا
برلين قطع الاضاءة ليلا عن عشرات
المباني العامة والمعالم في
الخارجية واغلاق المحلات اثناء
تشغيل التكييف. وكل ذلك من اجل
ان نؤمن مخزونا للطاقة من اجل
الشتاء. وهنا الظلام يخيم في
منظم للكهرباء لعدة ايام. وفي
تصعيد روسي مع الغرب قررت موسكو
وذلك قبل موسم الشتاء. والذي
يتوقع ان يكون صعبا على اوروبا
وربيع بوتين. هنا اوروبا تستعد
لانقطاع امدادات الغاز الروسي
لغزو الصين لتايوان. فمناوراتهم
قد تكون فضحت حيث يتم التركيز
المعتاد بل بسبب نقص حاد في
الطاقة. وقد اعلنت حكومة ولاية
ليبدأ النواح من بريطانيا حيث
تواجه عجزا في الكهرباء حتى بعد
المانيا وتحديدا برلين. ليس
احتفالا بساعة الارض كما هو
قبل فصل الشتاء حيث دخلت اليوم
خطة التقشف الاوروبي حيز التنفيذ
الى سوريا بخير وهو الان بين
اهله. ترامب يعتبر اسرار امريكا
الموصلات من اجل انظمة الاسلحة
الرئيسية. روسيا تعلن عن استضافة
البنتاجون قوله ان تقديرات وزارة
الدفاع تشير الى ان نحو ثمانين
ستقطع. نقلت فورين بوليسي
الامريكي عن مسؤول كبير في
نصر الله لبنان لن يتسامح مع من
ينهب ثرواته واي يد تمتد اليه
تشغيل محطات الفحم ونقلا عن
مصادر بريطانية. هناك خطط لقطع
النسكافيه ولم يتوقف الصراخ هناك
وصل صداه الى باريس. مملكة
خنقهم اكثر وذلك بقطع امدادات
النفط الروسية الى المجر وتشيك
دار للمسنين في مدينة اضمة.
الوزيرة اضافت ان ترحيلهم سيكون
اثارت جدلا واسعا بهذا التصريح.
نعم لاعادة السوريين الى بلادهم
بعد عام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين.
وذلك خلال مشاركتها في افتتاح
من الصدر لحل الازمة في العراق
وهو تشكيل حكومة لا يشارك فيها
حسب تعبيره ليرد البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس جو بايدن لا يعلم بامر
ستكشف لنا الايام القادمة?
الاحداث والتطورات. مقترح جديد
اي احد منهم وانه تم استضافة
السوريين ليس من اجل الرحمة فقط
اقبح العنصرية عندما تفوح
رائحتها من افواه المسئولين.
السجلات الحكومية قد يتعرض لسجن
لمدة لا تزيد عن ثلاث سنوات.
منزل ترامب حملها ترامب معه
اثناء مغادرة البيت الابيض. وعلق
القاها في المرحاض. وهنال
الامريكي يؤكد في المادة الثامنة
عقاب موسكو. كما قالها بوتين
العام القادم سيكون شتاء اوروبا
تقاتل من اجل منع تأسيس دولة
ارهابية في المنطقة الحدودية ما
وانما من اجل حدودها وان الجيش
السوري الحر والقوات التركية
خلال عام. هكذا قالت وزيرة
الاسرة التركية للسوريين. وقد
واشنطن من ضربتها الموجعة تجاه
موسكو. فكيف سيكون رد الروس على
ذلك? تركيا لا ترحب بكم. لن يكون
هناك اي لاجئ سوري في بلادنا
قهري بكسر خزانة ترامب والهدف
البحث عن وثائق وصفت بالخطيرة
ساصمت قليلا. لقد تم قصف الجبهة
بنجاح. سقوط في لحظات غير متوقعة
نفسك وزير خارجية تايوان. لست
سوى مدير لمكتب شؤون خارجية
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يوقع
على بروتوكول انضمام السويد
عسكري. البنتاجون يعترف. للمرة
الاولى وزارة الدفاع الامريكية
نفسها. وما علاقة وثائق ترامب
السرية بالمجنون? ومقترح عراقي
ففي جميع دول العالم مطاعم صينية
ايعني هذا انكم تمتلكون العالم؟
يأتي الرد من وزير الخارجية
الصيني. هاي انت يا من تطلق على
او بيلجاتشو او ما هو اسمك؟ اهذا
معيار تثبتون فيه ملكيتكم لدولة؟
لست قلقا بشأن الوضع في تايوان
لكنني قلق من تحركات الصين ولا
امداد كييف باسلحة جديدة ايضا من
اسقاط الصواريخ الروسية. هنا
على ستة منافذ رئيسية لتايوان.
وقيدت هذه النقاط حركة تايوان
المدينة. وفي هذه الساعات ربما
ستلمسون بعضا من معاناة السوريين
وفنلندا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي.
لتكون عضوا رسميا لقد اكثرت
نقطع الغاز الروسي ويجب على
المحلات التجارية اطفاء الانوار
وسلوفاكيا لقلبك القاسي يا
بوتين. فكيف سيدفئ الاوروبيون
ليلة رومانسية هادئة بل مرغمين
على ذلك. حيث صرح وزير الاقتصاد
الصين تدشن اول خطوة لغزو
تايوان. ووزارة الدفاع الامريكية
مشروطا بتطهير شمال سوريا من
الارهاب وخلال هذا العام لن يبقى
تعترف بتزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ
مضادة للرادار والهدف منها ضرب
مقرات الرادارات الروسية ولتعزيز
اعترافها هذا اعلنت كذلك عن
تعترف وبايدن يغضب الروس. فهل
ينفذ بوتين وعده? وقرار تركي
يصيب اللاجئين السوريين بخيبة
امل. واوروبا تبدأ في عقاب
جديد قد يكون مفتاحا لازمتهم
والجزائر تشارك روسيا في اول عمل
يوقع من اجل فنلندا والسويد فهل
يقرع الدب الروسي طبول الحرب?